I didn't hear her in six months because
I burnt my gym down oops I burnt my gym
down Britney Spears is starting little
fires everywhere the singer took to
Instagram to casually reveal to fans
that she accidentally burned her at home
gym down six months ago and just as soon
as she made the revelation Britney moved
right along launching into one of her
signature Instagram workout videos even
fans with more questions than answers
news of the fire didn't break when it
happened there's no word on who else was
home at the time and she posted no
photos of the aftermath but Britt
appears to be safe and that's really all
that matters I have really good people
around me that support me and what I do
with my daily life and so I'm really
blessed in another post from the same
day Britney revealed she was in
Louisiana before lockdown began oh we
party we party we have fun we act
completely complete idiots are so happy
to see each other so yeah the spears
family celebrated her sister jamie-lynns
29th birthday
jamie-lynn gave fans this tour of their
childhood home one person missing from
the festivities Brittany's boyfriend Sam
Ascari she posted that they've been
social distancing separately even
claiming she's lost weight for missing
him so much Sam opened up to et last
year about the possibility of them
getting married you guys have been
together almost three years now dude she
the one you see marriage in the future I
mean absolutely this is something that
every couple should do that's the whole
point of a relationship we're a family
yes absolutely
use your mom like sisters or anything I
have three sisters oh and they're like
yeah Sam's bringing home breeding
freakin Spears dinner was running out a
lot of times you know we've been
together for three years
well my sister's love her my family
loves her my mom lives in another
country when she was here she met her
[Music]